as acting mayor of bajena inen zaka
chenko presides over the most heavily
damaged town in the central keev region
nearly 2 years into Russia's fullscale
Invasion the streets and buildings still
bear the scars of when this community
was briefly and devastatingly on the
front line more than 5,000 people lost
their homes there was damage to more
than 2,000 private buildings 80
high-rise buildings schools
kindergartens and local government
facilities
slowly the town is being transformed
Arena's office at least now has windows
again projects such as this school built
with Lithuanian funding are replacing
what was destroyed but much more is
needed support from Europe is essential
for us to win this war we understand
that to rebuild our community the state
cannot do it on its own we need money
from European
donors EU funding is especially
significant
as a similarly sized Aid package from
the United States is being delayed
because of a political dispute in
Washington further Complicated by the
upcoming presidential election us
funding into Ukraine became hostage of
domestic us politics and it is very uh
hard for Ukraine to do anything with it
uh in in the year of presidential
elections in the United States Ukraine's
precarious existence looks set to
continue until it can become fully
integrated into the European Union
although EU leaders are likely to find
some work around to push through the
eight package this episode has revealed
just how vulnerable Ukraine is to any
delay in approving support a
vulnerability that many here believe
will only be overcome when it has the
security of full EU membership just
starting the lengthy process to join the
block Ukraine's priority is getting
sufficient funding to survive long
enough to see it through Rob McBride
aljazera banka
Ukraine make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer